Armel charrier
Sergueï la prof la parle de l'hystérie
occidentale on voit bien sûr que il veut
appuyer sur cette opposition entre la
Russie et le monde occidental oui
absolument il est dans ça justificatif
j'allais dire avec une vision très russe
de cette de ce conflit c'est d'ailleurs
bien ce qui nous oppose ce qui est
intéressant c'est que j'allais dire que
son phrase est classique effectivement
c'est de dire qu'on est en désaccord
avec les Ukrainiens etc etc mais quand
il parle d'hystérie ça c'est un terme
qui n'est pas habituel quand aussi il
pointe du doigt là le fait que dans la
liste des sanctions se sont rajoutées
aussi les sanctions sportives vous savez
ou du coup pour porter un tort aux
Russes on a décidé de ne plus les mettre
dans les fédérations dans les
fédérations de football etc il dit mais
finalement c'est un monde que vous avez
construit avec une logique qui faisait
que on se rencontrait on était les uns
avec les autres vous nous excluez de
tout ça et vous avez effectivement trop
loin alors c'est une ligne de fracture
quand même plus importante encore que à
la question de la sécurité telle qu'on
peut la voir en Ukraine et je trouve
qu'on va de plus en plus vers un rapport
de société c'est vraiment la Russie qui
se construit en fait en étant une
société un peu différente de la société
occidentale et qui est en train de dire
on veut avoir une autre vision du monde
on l'avait entendu déjà on avait posé
cette question quand on parlait de la
question sur l'homosexualité quand on
parlait la question sur justement la
question d'éducation sur la question de
l'histoire vous savez tout ce genre de
choses là qui est très à fleur de peau
dans la société aussi russe celle que la
veuve Vladimir Poutine en disant c'est
plus traditionnel c'est plus refermé etc
et là on entend effectivement que les
choses sont mêlées et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les Russes ont une
capacité de se défaire du côté
occidental parce que du coup ils
imaginent qu'ils vont se refaire du côté
asiatique avec évidemment comme allié la
Chine et l'Inde